[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOMOMI MATSUOKA: [INAUDIBLE]
LUKASZ KRAWCZYK: Good afternoon.
[LAUGHTER]
Good afternoon.
TOMOMI MATSUOKA: Thank you for
coming to this Talks at event.
My name is Tomomi.
I am program manager of
Google Earth Outreach.
Google Earth Outreach
is to introduce
our Geo tools, Google's
Geo tools, to NPOs,
and educators, and
then the researchers,
and the scientists.
And one of Geo tools
is Earth Engine.
Earth Engine is petabyte
planetary-scale analysis
platform.
You can access to
40 years satellite
imagery and more
than 200 observation
data and the computation power.
And then through Earth
Engine initiatives,
I got to know the company,
this start-up, Axelspace.
And then I get so excited
to know about this exciting
start-up, so I cannot help
inviting them to provide
a talk.
So they will explain about their
mission and then a little bit
engineering stuff.
I mean, the coding stuff--
maybe?
No coding.
Yeah.
LUKASZ KRAWCZYK: Coding, OK.
Next time.
TOMOMI MATSUOKA:
And then-- yeah.
So please welcome
Lukasz from Axelspace.
LUKASZ KRAWCZYK: Yes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much
for introduction.
My name is Lukasz.
And today, I'm going to talk
how we can protect forests
from space.
First, let me introduce myself.
So I came to Japan
several years ago.
I've been working
mainly in start-ups.
And I graduated from
Jagiellonian University
in Poland, in Krakow.
And now I'm working as a
space business intelligence
engineer at Axelspace.
And I have several hobbies.
One of them is open source.
Hand craft-- mainly wood
and [INAUDIBLE] instruments.
So a few words about
my company, Axelspace--
have you ever heard?
Has any one of you heard
about Axelspace before?
1, 2, 3, 4.
Whoa.
Oh.
That's a lot, which is
really good, obviously.
So Axelspace is, in my
opinion, an amazing company.
So we are a team of
approximately 60 people,
most of them hardware
and software engineers.
And we have two offices
in Tokyo, in Nihonbashi.
And what makes us different
from other hardware and software
start-ups is that we are making
satellites in our office.
So actually, to
be more specific,
these are microsatellites.
To give you idea of
what's the difference
between microsatellite
and normal satellite,
please have a look
at this photo.
Here on the right side, we
have a normal satellite, NASA
or ESA satellite.
It's basically a few tons.
And here on the
photo on the left,
you can see one of our
smallest microsatellite, which
is just a few--
10 centimeters.
So the main difference is size.
And the other difference
is, obviously, price.
So we are building those
satellites in our office.
We are testing them.
And we are launching
them to low earth orbit.
Yeah, this is Soyuz rocket.
So during the last
few years, we've
developed-- we've launched
several microsatellites
to orbit.
These were really
successful missions.
And at the moment,
we are working
on a constellation of
satellites and also
in parallel on quite a
big project for JAXA.
So today's topic is how we can--
sorry-- how can we protect
forests from space?
So maybe first let
me briefly explain
what's the relation between
forest and human, what
are the economical and
control links between them.
Approximately 30% of Earth land
area is occupied by forests.
So these are these blue,
green areas here mainly.
And there are basically
three types of forests.
First one is boreal
forest, mainly
on the Northern Hemisphere
near polar regions,
where temperatures are
really, really low.
Second one is temperate
forests, warm regions
mainly in the Northern
Hemisphere, also in Japan.
Moderate temperature
and rainfalls.
And the third one
is tropical forest
near the equator, where
temperatures are really high,
high humidity, and very,
very heavy rainfalls.
So what makes-- what's
special about rainforest,
about tropical
forest, is that it's
a home for hundreds of
thousands of living species.
And sadly, 50% of tropical
forest is already destroyed.
So what are the main human
activities related to forests?
What do you think?
What are the main activities,
except logging, except cutting?
Some ideas?
Camping maybe, trekking.
AUDIENCE: They burn the forest
to gain crop [INAUDIBLE]..
LUKASZ KRAWCZYK: Exactly, yes.
So forest conversion
into agriculture.
So this is also one of activity.
In fact, there
are a lot of them.
When you think about it,
urban planning, cleaning land
for mines and solar panel--
solar power plants, access
to natural resources,
disaster prevention,
agriculture,
academic research-- there are
a lot of different activities.
In fact, we are very strongly
connected with forest.
The problem is that we are
doing some of these things
too much in an
uncontrollable way sometimes.
So especially it
becomes clear when
you look at the Earth from
different perspective,
from higher perspective,
directly, actually, from space.
The size of
deforestation is amazing.
This is the photo taken by
one of our satellite in New
Zealand.
It's the southern
part of New Zealand.
And it's really shocking.
So to put it into numbers,
13.7 million hectares a year
are cut down.
So I don't know if you are
interested in football,
but probably you
have some impression
of how big a football pitch is.
So this is basically 19 million
football pitches every year.
It's hard to imagine.
But it's unfortunately true.
And the problem is that only
50% of this forest is replanted.
So what are the
influenced areas?
Mainly, basically, whole world.
Climate change, loss of
natural habitat, soil erosion,
flooding, greenhouse
emissions-- those things
have very negative effect on
different commercial activities
and then the human health.
If we look at it by region, then
you can see that during last, I
think, 20, 30 years, Brazil
lost approximately 15%
of forest coverage.
Ethiopia, up to 90%.
Madagascar, 90%.
Nigeria, 80% within
last 15 years only.
Oh, I'm sorry.
And then Asia-- minus 40%.
These are really bad examples.
However, there are
also good examples,
like China and Europe, also
Canada and United States.
So some of you might think, why?
What's the difference?
Why we have such a
huge deforestation
in this region but we have--
the situation's actually
opposite and different?
So this is a very
interesting thing,
and a lot of researchers,
a lot of organizations
are investigating this topic.
And there are several ideas.
One of them is called
Kuznets curve effect.
Basically, we are observing
increased deforestation
in tropical regions and
decreased deforestation
in highly developed areas.
There might be a lot of
reasons for that situation.
One of them is definitely
demand for wood
has changed during
the last few years,
especially in highly
developed countries.
But probably the biggest
problem is that we
are outsourcing deforestation.
But it's really hard to say.
There is no clear idea what
is the biggest reason, how
to change that trend,
because simply, we
don't have enough data.
Data is not accessible enough.
So there are a lot of ideas,
solutions how to improve,
how to fight this
kind of problem.
Definitely, increased
awareness of this problem
has led to a lot of big
changes in regional law,
in international agreements.
A lot of countries are
creating protected areas
to protect forest.
There are a lot of amazing
organizations which
are monitoring and gathering
data, like from Africa,
and different
analysis companies.
So how to improve
this situation?
At Axelspace, we think
that one of the solution
is to improve planet-scale
monitoring through fast access
to data, affordable access
to data, high quality
analysis-ready data,
and tools to analyze it,
as well as communication
and knowledge sharing.
Our solution is
called AxelGlobe.
And it's a constellation
of satellites
which will help us to photograph
entire world every day
at 2.5 meter resolution.
To better understand how we
can use this constellation,
let's have a look
at a short video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ROCKET ENGINE ROARING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
OK, so we are going to
use our constellation
to monitor whole Earth
daily, accumulate the data,
analyze it, and deliver it
to various organizations,
companies, and governments
to be able to analyze data,
to see how we can
change this situation.
So AxelGlobe solves several
of the problems, several
of needs I mentioned before.
First of all, fast
access to data.
Web platform and API--
we are building it now--
will help basically
anyone to access data
from entire world every day
for really a cheap price.
It's approximately few dollars
per one square kilometer.
And our constellation
will provide high quality
analysis-ready data with
high temporal, spatial,
and spectral resolution
in a standardized way.
All data will be processed
and analyzed, so ready to use.
And so probably this
is most important slide
here-- how AxelGlobe will
help protecting forest land.
First of all, by lowering
cost of monitoring.
Imagine-- well, let's go back
to the previous picture here.
Imagine how long it will take to
monitor this real forest using
drones, using
helicopters or airplanes,
how expensive it would be.
However, with satellites,
satellites is always in orbit.
So you can take
the photo anyway--
anytime you want.
So definitely it will
help to reduce the cost
and basically lower
the barrier for entry
to improve monitoring.
And the insights will
be much more accessible.
Second point is
forest health analysis
through land cover
classification and then plant
health analysis.
To better understand
this topic, let
me briefly explain what
electromagnetic spectrum is.
I think most of you
here are engineers.
So our satellites will
focus on a specific part
of electromagnetic
spectrum, which
is between 400 nanometers
and 900 nanometers, which
is basically visible light
plus infrared spectrum,
near-infrared spectrum.
Fortunately for us,
this part of spectrum
is visible through
atmosphere, which
is not that obvious
because there
are some other areas of the
spectrum which atmosphere
is not [INAUDIBLE] to.
Yep.
So by using machine learning
and especially deep learning,
we are able to categorize,
to classify terrain
to measure the area covered by
forest, by fields, by cities
and to understand how that area
is changing over time, which is
very important for monitoring.
We can therefore
detect also logging,
especially illegal logging.
Here is another example.
Also, one of very
interesting characteristics
of this electromagnetic
spectrum we are focusing on
is that plants are
reflecting two parts
of electromagnetic spectrum.
One is green light, what we
see in our eyes as green light.
Another is infrared.
Unfortunately, we can't see it,
but we can sense it from space.
And also, one more important
thing, interesting thing
here is that the more
plant is healthy,
the stronger it reflects
infrared-- near-infrared part
of the spectrum, as you
can see here on the graph.
So by monitoring this
thing from space,
we can very easily say whether--
as here, on this example,
whether a plant is healthy
or not.
This is really small scale, but
if we look at a bigger scale,
there is-- yeah, there is
some small forest in town.
And here, you can see that
this part on the right-hand
is probably affected
by some kind of disease
or some kind of insect.
So just by taking
one photo from space,
we can understand that
something is happening,
and we should probably
send in drones or a human
for an inspection.
And this is on
even larger scale.
And again, how long it will
take to monitor this area using
even a helicopter?
And a third point is alerting.
So coverage measurements I
mentioned before and object
and activity detection.
This is also what
we are focusing on.
Basically, this is the example
from Kumamoto earthquake.
It was last year, as
far as I remember.
And by analyzing the difference
between subsequent photos
from the same area, you can
easily detect changes, like,
in this case, landslides.
So even if a certain area
doesn't have infrastructures
to go to investigate
what's happening,
we can always take
photo from space.
So it helps to act faster.
Yeah, so this brings me to
the end of this presentation.
So as I mentioned
in the beginning,
there is a deep connection
between forest and human.
And deforestation is
really a huge problem.
However, we have the technology.
We have ideas how to
solve this problem,
how to at least
improve the situation.
So we strongly
believe that AxelGlobe
will help to protect forest
through fast and affordable
access to high quality
data and insights,
through lowering costs of
monitoring and alerting,
and forest health analysis
basically on the planet scale.
I think we still
have some time, no?
So maybe I'll give you--
I will show you several photos
from our previous satellites
to give you some glimpse
into how beautiful photos
we can take from space.
So this is-- ah,
thank you very much.
Yeah.
So this is South America.
Yeah, southern part
of South America.
There is a glacier
there which is still not
affected by global warming.
This is a really beautiful
photo of a river in Madagascar.
This is Mount Fuji in Japan.
And this is one small island
in the French Polynesia.
And this is called
the Eye of Sahara.
It's in Mauritania,
as far as I remember.
And this photo was
taken in Algeria.
Sand dunes.
And Italy.
Minnesota, USA,
taken last winter.
Everything covered in snow.
And south part of New Zealand.
Colorado, USA.
And yeah, some plants
in Saudi Arabia.
Bay of Hong Kong in China.
So more at AxelGlobe.com.
You can visit.
You can see much
more photos there.
You can enjoy how Earth
is beautiful there.
[END PLAYBACK]